bonsoir et bienvenue en kiosque que
votre émission culturelle tout de suite
le sommaire et caroline elle est et
irène clara expo jusqu'au 19 juin à la
maison de la poésie de guyancourt elle
présente un travail autour de la
sculpture et les encres de chine elles
seront en plateau pour nous en parler le
coeur de ci de là des quais sous bois en
représentation ce week-end pour un
programme autour de mozart et de vivaldi
portrait de cette chorale emmenée par
sandrine coccyx coeur une femme à
l'énergie débordante
le festival alternatiba c'est tout ce
week end à la verrière autour du thème
du développement durable des tables
rondes des concerts des ateliers nicolas
gervais a rencontré l'une des
responsables associatifs avant tout cela
je propose donc d'ouvrir une page
exposition irène clara et carolina et
expose en ce moment à la maison de la
poésie de guyancourt d encre de chine
pour irène clara et des sculptures pour
caroline ouellette vous êtes toutes les
deux en plateau bonsoir à vous
caroline des tout cet artiste
plasticienne c'est la première fois que
peu exposé à la maison de la poésie à
guyancourt
mais je rappelle quand même que vous
donnez aussi des cours à guyancourt et à
voisins le bretonneux alors parlez nous
de ce travail que vous présentez à la
maison de la poésie parce que c'est
aussi la première fois que vous
présentez ces détails d'écriture
exactement donc à la maison de la poésie
je présente un travail que j'ai commencé
au début de cette année qui est dans la
continuité de mon travail sur le temps
mais sur l'esthétique de la ruine j'ai
travaillé sur des plaques de béton avec
des encres de chine et des pigments
lorsque le béton était frais
vous demandez pas ce que comment mettre
l'encré de chine dans le béton il faut
quand même qu'ils soient là en fait un
travail sur trois jours en fait j'étais
l'on travaille sur trois jours et
ensuite je viens graver ses plaques avec
différents symboles qui sont en fait des
symboles de ma vie actuelle de ce qui me
marque c'est souvent ça fait souvent
rabat rapport à des aspects personnels
de vie voilà donc ce sont des étapes
d'écriture c'est un travail sur le temps
c'est comme s'ils ont retrouvé des des
vieux morceaux de murs des vieilles
plaques dans 2000 ans avec un matériau
qui nous est aujourd'hui contemporain
qu'elle béton donc aujourd'hui je
travaille essentiellement avec lever
très justement pourquoi le béton parce
que vous auriez pu faire le choix de la
gravure
oui en fait le béton ça fait cinq ans à
peu près que je travaille le béton est
en fait j'ai choisi ce matériel en
passant par la photographie
j'ai commencé par faire des robes movie
photographique dans la ville nouvelle de
saint quentin
c'est un travail pareil identitaire pour
arrêter mon regard sur sur un paysage
quotidien des paysages que je regardais
plus forcément et j'ai eu envie d'en
créer mes photos dans le matériau de mon
environnement de ma ville donc j'ai
choisi de faire des tirages
photographiques sur plaques de béton
j'ai commencé à travailler avec le béton
comme ça j'ai ensuite fait des arrêts
sur image en racontant des histoires
personnelles toujours au travers
d'installations de sculptures mail en
béton fer à béton
j'ai exposé des très grosses pièces qui
font plus de 500 kg la sonde étapes
d'écriture qui font entre 30 cm sur 30 m
voilà et la suite de ce travail là
j'avais envie de passer sur surduts sur
des signes sur sur de l'écriture et donc
j'ai j'ai développé cette technique la
ddt de table de table et d'écriture sur
béton vous parlez de votre histoire
personnelle vous parlez de symbole est
ce que dans ces symboles que vous mettez
y aussi votre histoire en bouquet est
intéressante puisque vous avez repris
vos études pour faire l'école des
beaux-arts à 30 ans avant que vous étiez
dans les ressources humaines dont
quasiment rien à vous
elle renonce et d'étranges des liens
encore plus personnel qui n'ont rien du
tout et avons rien à perdre justement
qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui te fait qu'à
un moment donné dans sa vie on se dit je
change de situation je passe des
ressources humaines vous étiez ouais
ouais ouais bon à la fois de
techniquement très organisée à l'école
des beaux-arts et un monde culturel
différement s était c'était un besoin
je pense que quand on est fait pour pour
les arts on peut pas s'en défaire
et j'avais l'impression que ma vie
passée certes très intéressant qu'on
n'avait pas vraiment de sens voilà il
n'y avait pas il y avait pas mal ça il
ya dix ans maintenant il ya du sosie et
vous êtes installé à saint jean de
beauregard dans le dans l'essonne
exactement j'ai mon atelier à une fois
de découvrir aux ateliers plus tôt au
mois d'octobre à l'occasion des deux
journées portes portes ouvertes vous
exposez maison de la poésie avec irène
clara bonsoir vous êtes peintre depuis
40 ans vous exposer régulièrement dans
l'agglomération est ici donc à la maison
de la poésie on proposait pas des ehpad
étapes d'écriture mais des encres de d
encre de chine qu'est ce qui vous plaît
dans l'encré de chine dans ce travail
est bien l'encré de chine manduel a
quelque chose de tout à fait particulier
parce que la meuse dans la mesure où je
la travaille sur papier japonais qui est
après collé sur un support aux petits
papiers à wembley où concilie à
l'interaction entre l'anc en tant que
terre et les fibres du papier --selon la
tenue du papier l'encré agir
différemment alors il y à cette
exposition que j'avais proposé à jacques
fournier qui d'ailleurs s'intitule les
encres prennent la parole parce que j'ai
pensé qu' il y avait effectivement un
lien entre la plume de l'écrivain est
lent qu'en tant que tel est ce que
j'essaye au niveau de mes travaux
c'est de faire voir de l'invisible en
fait je crois que pascual invisible à la
compta fait je crois que je pourrais
dire que
je revendique une démarche un peu
poétique qui essaie de chercher au delà
de ce qui est visible quelque chose qui
sous jacent mon dieu c'est peut-être une
manière de définir l'abstrait dire que
derrière ce qui est là concret figuratif
à votre portée de main déchiffrable il y
a d'autres choses il ya des structures
il ya des flux il ya des mouvements
il ya tout un univers qui nous échappent
et qui peut être bon ou rapproche un
tout petit peu d'art car presque
microcosmique sur les choses donc chacun
on regarde on vaut en oeuvre peut partir
dans son imaginaire se lève pour voir
quelque chose seulement avoir seulement
je venais celle de liberté aux
spectateurs de s'y retrouver
vous présentez 16 encre deux films à
cette occasion et ça demandait beaucoup
de travail oui oui oh oui oui disons que
j'ai travaillé pour cette exposition du
piano il y avait ce projet est donc ça
m'a pris allemande de faire cette
réalisation d'ailleurs j'étais très
heureuse de la sphère ce n'était pas la
première fois parce que auparavant on
avait organisé dans la même maison de la
poésie des expositions où il y avait
rencontre entre graveur et écrivain
puisque là aussi il y a la même démarche
il ya 7 mai si cela vous fait une
exposition commune avec une lettre c'est
parce qu'il ya qu est ce qui vous
rapproche alors toutes les deux mais je
travaille sur la creuse
c'est à dire qu'il y à il ya
effectivement un tournant que caroline a
pris qui est fort intéressant mais qui
lui est propre qui ne serait pas le mien
puisque le béton j'en ai de très grave
souvenir lorsque je m'étais moi même le
carrelage sur une terrasse je le faisais
avec les mains et mes mains après
étaient à vif donc jamais je
travaillerai ni langue dans le béton
mais il dit
c'est une c'est une exposition que vous
complétez toutes les deux exposés
jusqu'au 19 juin à la maison de la
poésie je profite quand même bien de
cartes votre venue en plateau pour bien
si vous êtes la présidente de peau et ce
qui est que évidemment vous défendez
beaucoup en ce moment
la maison de la poésie quand on annonce
la fermeture en tout cas des locaux la
mission poésie ne sera reprise au sein
au réseau des médiathèques et c'est
important pour vous défendre la maison
de la poésie aujourd'hui voile alors je
vous remercie énormément de me donner
cette occasion parce que je voulais
rappeler quelques petits fait bon la
création de la maison de la poésie
elle a été créée en 2002 elle l'a 13 ans
d'activité il y à un festival tout et
devil in qui a été créé en 2004 qui est
présente dans 80 communes 80 comme moi
la danse est devenue un point de départ
alors des partis comme voilà on n'ose 11
ans il y as 350 poète de 40 pays
différents qui sont venus se présenter à
cette maison de la poésie par année
scolaire il ya 15 à 25 classes de la
maternelle ou le lycée qui accueille un
poète pour un cycle de quatre à six
rencontres
il y as par an une dizaine de spectacles
dont 50% en création depuis 2006 il y à
la prise dans ces la fédération
européenne des maisons de poésie qui a
été créée en 2005
regroupant à ce jour quelque 35 lieux en
europe il ya des partenariats importants
avec tous les lieux culturels de saint
quentin en yvelines dans la scène
nationale avec l'ambassade de roumanie
avec un mr internationale le pen club
français la maison de la poésie
participe depuis mai quatre axes marché
au delà de 50 ans comment au-delà des
frontières même du département mais
complètement
nous avons des retours d'ailleurs au
niveau d'une pétition que nous avons
lancée chez sur change.org nous avons
des réponses qui nous viennent du québec
qui nous viennent avec plusieurs
milliers de signatures effectivement
nous sommes à plus de 3000 pour la
pétition en ligne
il ya bien davantage encore au niveau
des pétitions en papier il ya d'autres
actions qui seront honorées vu une
affaire en or à l'eau et à la sauver de
leur part mais des actions réalisées
autour de la maison de la poésie qui
fait l'objet d'une fermeture prochaine
merci en tout cas vous d'être mercato de
croiser pour parler de votre exposition
commune jusqu'au 19 juin donc à la
maison de la poésie
lui encore merci à mr 600 pages festival
ce week-end c'est le festival
alternatiba à la verrière nicolas
gervais nous parle du programme avec
élise héros de l'association dédale
développement durable conférences
spectacles débats concerts ou encore aux
stands informatifs le festival
alternatiba c'est les 6 et 7 juin à
saint quentin en yvelines et plus
précisément à la verrière alors un
nouveau festival à saint quentin en
yvelines forcément c'est mais c'est
super non c'est en le cédant le sait
dans le kiosque
c'est dans le chat c'est super non mais
cette saison le coeur mais oui c'est
super mais c'est dans le kiosque
alternatiba c'est à la fois un mouvement
national voire européen de mobilisation
citoyenne et alternatiba c'est aussi un
festival des alternatives alors pour
pour la petite histoire en octobre 2013
donc l'association basque bizi qui est
située à bayonne a organisé à un village
des alternatives pour le climat la
justice sociale ça s'est passé donc à
bayonne donc ils ont occupé le centre
ville c'était sans voiture et partout où
vous pouvez voir des porteurs
d'alternatives dans différents domaines
dans l'éducation les transports à
travers des ateliers des conférences et
il y avait aussi plein de
plein de concerts de danse d'exposition
les dalles avait depuis un petit moment
envie de faire un festival des
alternatives et il se trouve que après
le grand succès qui a été le alternative
à bayonne on a eu envie de faire pareil
en alternative à un village des
alternatives et donc là ça fait un an et
demi qu'il y en ait que des habitants
les citoyens des associatifs travaillent
ensemble pour organiser donc ce festival
des internes hâtivement ce sera des 6 et
7 juin à la verrière on attend et on a
besoin de 200 bénévoles
ce festival de tout saint quentin en
yvelines va prendre place à la verrière
plus particulièrement dans le parc de la
mgen et au niveau de la plaine du
scarabée
donc il va y avoir 12 quartiers
thématiques donc sur le thème de l'éco
habitat des déchets transports de la
culture de la démocratie
on a prévu 75 exposants une cinquantaine
de spectacles donc à la fois des
concerts des pièces de théâtre de
décompte des grandes conférences des
ateliers aussi parce qu'on voudrait que
les gens soient acteurs allemands
participent
dans ce festival donc beaucoup
d'ateliers comme par exemple réparation
de vélo aura différents styles et des
groupes à la fois locaux et à la fois
nationaux donc au niveau des groupes
locaux
on aura par exemple red rooster et un
groupe de blues on va voir ni origin qui
est un groupe
de reggae de maurepas
on va voir los tres puntos en 15 rounds
ce cas qui existe depuis 20 ans qui
viendra donc le dimanche
dimanche 7 juin au scarabée on va voir
aussi hk hk et les saltimbanks voilà qui
sort un nouvel album et on est très
heureux de voir d'accueillir ces
notamment si d'hollywood lors de ce
festival
on a cherché
on va voir des orchestres comme
l'ensemble de cuivres de mon moulin qui
est de guyancourt on va avoir une
chorale les rouges-gorges qui est une
chorale de chants de lutte
on va voir l'association balivernes qui
va proposer un atelier de danse folk
parents enfants lors de ce festival il y
aura beaucoup d'animations pour les
enfants pour le jeune public
par exemple dans l'espace éducation et
pédagogie on aura beaucoup de
de compte on va voir des lectures des
contes
on va voir aussi une pièce de théâtre
donc de la compagnie p&o chaki un
spectacle pour enfants qui sera suivie
d'un débat avec des agriculteurs donc
sur le thème de l'alimentation de
l'agriculture
pour espère avoir 5000 personnes voire
plus qui viendront pour découvrir des
alternatives des solutions concrètes et
aussi pour là pour passer du bon temps
ce échangé ce qu'on attend de ce
festival c'est que ce soit vraiment une
belle fête populaire où les gens
s'approprient le festival où les gens
découvre mais aussi
à porte il ya déjà des porteurs
d'alternatives qui sont présents il ya
par exemple une coopérative de
production d'énergie locale qui va être
lancée lors de ce festival bonne canal
il ya du combat temps qu'on passe des
coulées de boue
tant qu'on est debout relâchera pas la
rage de vaincre coule dans nos veines
maintenant tu sais pourquoi onze par nos
petits des halles bien plus qu à l est
notre monde la boîte soit en arrière en
lâche rien
on n'a rien
voilà un festival alternatif dont vous
êtes maintenant au courant
pas besoin de faire de deuxième prise
retrouve catherine tout de suite et moi
je file
allez on ne lâche rien festival toujours
les 5 6 et 7 juin la firme brion de
chavenay accueille la deuxième édition
du printemps de la plaine de versailles
ce festival de thèmes de théâtre en
plein air rassemble des artistes locaux
autour de plusieurs pièces on voit ici
elle les répétitions stand up scène
ouverte où adaptation il y en aura pour
tous les goûts
on écoute les aidants organisateurs
alors cette année on a un plateau assez
intéressant puisque vous auront deux
pièces de carlo boso durant le festival
on aura pétanque et sentiments de
bernard pide et on rejouera pour la
deuxième année le spectacle impertinence
de juliet lemonnier et le but c'est de
sortir en plein air et de trouver un
lieu qui auront qui est comme vous
pouvez voir un superbe pour interpréter
et c'est agréable où elle juin quand il
fait beau et rien de tel
j'ai créé un seul en scène qui s'appelle
impertinence autour de d'une douzaine de
fables de la fontaine que je que je
revisite où je m'amuse beaucoup j'essaie
de d'incarner les animaux ce n'est que
des pièces que des fables avec des
animaux ça a tout son sens de jouer de
jouer en plein air et de parce que les
animaux sont en plein air et
et c'est encore mieux de pouvoir jouer
avec le l'environnement et si vous aimez
le théâtre un autre festival est
proposée cette fois la ferme de bel ébat
du 10 au 14 juin pour la quatrième
saison la salle de guyancourt invite les
troupes locales à présenter leurs
spectacles au programme donc la troupe
des korrigans celle des technocentre
renault ou encore d'anim europe entrée
libre sur réservation la chorale de si
de là sera en concert le samedi 6 juin
en l'église saint martin des
clayes-sous-bois le choeur sera
accompagné d'un quintette à cordes pour
un concert classique autour du credo de
vivaldi et d'une messe de mozart nous
avons suivi les dernières répétitions
dernière répétition pour le coeur de ci
de là école marcel pagnol aux
clayes-sous-bois c'est dans cette salle
de classe que l'on retrouve la chef de
choeur
sandrine compte six coeurs et ses
cinquante choristes pour un concert à
une semaine de la représentation s'est
entourée du quintette à cordes merak
qu'ils entament la dernière répétition
le programme cette année centrée sur
mozart vivaldi haydn de l'ambition qui a
nécessité une certaine exigence physique
des oeuvres classiques et baroque met
paradoxalement qui nécessite énormément
d'investissement physique du corps a
simplement des cordes vocales et de
chanter juste avec la hauteur des notes
mais vraiment de de se mettre en route
avec tout son corps de soutenir d'avoir
une énergie débordante et parfois
l'énergie on a du mal à la trouver où
aller la trouver au bon endroit
parmi les choristes benoît mincir chefs
opérateurs sont dans les vies civiles et
basse au sein de la courir plus
difficile c'est la mise en place comme
dit comme dit sandrine c'est de faire de
la musique tous ensemble c'est à dire
que de se détacher détacher son regard
de la partition et pouvoir
dire comme unité avec le
avec le chef ce concert c'est le fruit
d'une saison de travail de préparation à
raison de deux heures par semaine et de
plusieurs dimanches dans l'année un
travail exigeant rendue possible par
l'ambiance qui règne au sein du groupe
et par la personnalité énergique de la
chef de choeur d'aucuns diraient que je
suis quelqu'un d'à peu près survoltée
voilà je pense surtout que faut avoir la
passion et l'amour de ce qu'on fait et
je crois énormément dans les capacités
et dans le potentiel du coeur que je
fais travailler je les pousse je les
tire je fais tout ce que je peux pour
que voilà à la fois ça sent bien et
surtout qu'ils se fassent plaisir se
faire plaisir et toujours progresser
pour s'en rendre compte il suffit
d'assister à l'une des répétitions
janvier 2015 les choristes découvre la
partition au fur et à mesure une séance
démarre toujours de la même manière
d'abord la mise en voix du corps
s'attacher à la respiration puis avant
le travail en commun la phase
d'apprentissage par pupitres les halles
qui les basses et les sopranos ce
regroupement niveau pour travailler
leurs morceaux nous retrouvons benoît le
chef opérateur sont il entama sa
cinquième saison au sein de la chorale
dans son enfance il a fait dix ans de
piano et de chant
j'aime la musique et puis j'aime aussi
là le spectacle et de mettre en danger
face à un public et donner de soi même
non on ne ralentit pas c'est pas parce
que ce sont juste de notes tenues qu'il
faut qu'il faut relâcher le relâcher la
tension on est bien conservé cet état
rythmique et pour lui qui a l'oreille
absolue pas question de manquer une auto
ou une respiration
il connaît les partitions parker l'outil
essentiel d'un choriste c'est son grand
papier sodome
vente pour tous repérés pour pour le
moindre petit détail ne serait ce qu un
ou deux choristes même si on est 50 60
ans et voilà le public un peu exercé en
tant ses petits défauts qui font toute
la différence de la qualité des décors
direction les alti avec celle que l'on
appelle la petite maman du coeur ou des
graviers
elle a intégré la chorale il ya vingt
ans dans le champ commun ce qui me plaît
m'a déjà que ce sont des chants sacrés
et manger toujours été élevé dans une
école chrétienne banques
un plus et je trouve que le fait de
chanter on oublie tous ces soucis le
niveau est assez haut se taisait mais
avec sandrine ben je vais aller elle
nous fait progresser à chaque fois
l'instrument c'est notre corps en entier
de la racine des cheveux à la plante des
pieds et même quand on est fatigué
parfois le fait de chanter ça détend la
galvanisa donne de l'énergie
sandrine constituant la pierre angulaire
de cette chorale elle a fondé le coeur
il ya 20 ans à l'époque une dizaine de
personnes composaient le groupe
aujourd'hui ils sont une cinquantaine
les choristes seront sur la scène de
l'église saint-martin décret sous bois
le 6 juin
avant d'entamer une autre série de
concerts dans la région oui je suis très
fier d'eux mêmes season lord pas et
voilà je suis très fier de ces deux
affaires de vous voilà une belle énergie
pour le ce groupe toujours en chant
choral saint quentin un gospel en
concert samedi 6 juin à 20h45 au cap
saint jacques de guyancourt cette
chorale de gospel qui regroupe 70
choristes et musiciens a déjà donné plus
de 150 représentations tarif 12 euros
et puis un autre concert du groupe vocal
cette fois cadence ce samedi soir au
centre alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux sous la direction
de son de sa nouvelle chef lara fenaille
le groupe vocal sera accompagnée au
piano par benjamin brenets au programme
des oeuvres de mendelssohn bruckner
brahms et forêts plein tarif à 15 euros
on passe à ton cinéma
et la chronique cinéphiles comme tous
les mercredis avec tout d'abord vos avis
de spectateurs au micro d' elodie moines
les émouvants de ça raconte une belle
histoire entre c'est enfin entre ses
amis qui découvre sa maladie et qui le
soutiennent jusqu'au bout ses projets il
ya tout en fait on rigole pas mal et en
même temps c'est un petit peu très
émouvant et mais c'est quand même un bon
film de bons acteurs aussi très très
bien c'est un très bon film
après je suis venu le voir je
connaissais pas trop lui l'histoire mais
c'est assez assez sympa une jolie
histoire d'amour j'ai bien aimé
matthieussent connacht
très séduisant très beau chine winter
berg connaissait sa mettant en scène
danois et je trouve que c'est une très
très bonne adaptation du roman je
trouvais que c'était un bon film c'est
intéressant c'est sur les nouvelles
technologies et donc je trouve que le
thème il est assez intéressant
voici un film de science fiction sur les
robots mais bon peut-être qu'un jour les
robots ils font pareil se vengeront
d'êtres humains ouais c'est pas mal
c'est vraiment bien et maintenant on
passe au coup de coeur d'un
professionnel du septième art ce soir le
pot quand j'ai signé cette d'elancourt
mon coup de coeur cette semaine c'est un
très beau film qui marche pas du tout en
salle mais que nous avons pour la
deuxième semaine consécutive et je vous
encourage vraiment à venir voir c'est le
dernier film d'arnaud desplechin qui
s'appelle trois souvenirs de ma jeunesse
un très très beau film avec notamment
des acteurs inconnus enfin totalement
quasiment inconnus qui sont excellents
donc c'est une très belle histoire
romantique qui parlent d'amour un film
un peu à l'ancienne moi j'ai accroché
avec au cinéma de despléchin à partir
d'un conte de noël et c'est vraiment un
très beau film très bien écrit très très
bien réalisé encore une fois très bien
interprété venez soutenir ce film qui
marche pas en salle donc on a à la fiche
aussi dès cette semaine et puis un
deuxième puis quelques rapides pour la
nuit mad max qui aura lieu samedi à
partir de 20h30 aussi 17 avec le premier
enfin le dernier plutôt bad max fury
road qui est
cinématographique en soit c'est vraiment
deux heures de course poursuite
ininterrompue très brillante fade en son
genre c'est vraiment un film film
d'action le blockbuster américain road
movie course poursuite
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais vus
au cinéma c'est très très bien faire et
ce sera suivi des deux premiers max qui
sont les deux meilleurs de la première
trilogie on va dire le avec mel gibson
évidemment mad max un frein qui
s'appelle mad max d'ailleurs et mad max
2 voilà ça samedi à 20h30 aussi 17
c'était mission maintenant terminé merci
de l'avoir suivi rendez vous mercredi
prochain d'ici là à garder l'esprit
ouvert et curieux
bonne semaine